and uh Magnus maybe you can tell us what
you've been doing in Baku first of all
I've got to ask do you miss having me
out there
um
you know I've actually uh I've actually
gotten used to it but of course
um
are you gonna be on the golf course
Queen G1 is also a nice way to finish
the game for uh for Arjun uh for sorry
for uh for Prague
because you can never take the pawn on
G2 C2 because okay Queen D2 jackets
whatever
um no it was very nice that uh at the
start to
um to have you and Aryan there of course
[Music]
um
like to actually like have people that I
hang out with at home at the tournament
this is is nice but um
you know I'm used to being a bit of a
loner at tournaments so it's um it's
it's it's it's fine I'm getting by and
now I know for sure that I will play two
more matches so now I might as well try
and win the tournaments